amid the shock of loss like questions
about how and why the Titan disappeared
and foremost among them is a single
query was this ever safe
the submersible was never certified for
use but a loophole allowed it to operate
at the Titanic wreck side as in these
previous missions because these are
international waters
five years ago the Marine technology
Society wrote to Ocean Gate saying it
feared the company's experimental
approach could result in negative
outcomes from minor to catastrophic it
was a dispute that was never resolved
and still haunts one of the writers of
that letter to do five passengers it
does push the envelope and you've got to
do the numbers right Ocean Gate was
taking a strategy of well we are we we
we
intentionally break the rules because we
can do it better and faster it leaves us
in a very tragic situation all of us in
this technical field are sincerely
driven by a deep duty of care and
unfortunately that takes
the submersible industry is a thriving
one this Dutch company sells models for
exploration research and personal use
unlike the Titan vessel these all have
to pass a long process of safety checks
before they can be sold certify the
design they certify the materials and
they they will inspect every stage of
the build and once a submarine is ready
we will go with them to the actual
diving depth of these submarines and
test every safety system again and again
for each submarine and by the time we're
finished we'll have a half container
load of paperwork these machines don't
go anywhere near the depth of Titan
they're designed to fall hundreds not
thousands of meters but they do tell us
something about what it must have been
like on board this subversible is very
different from Titan it's got much
better Communications it's more modern
you've got these acrylic screens so you
can see outside but a big similarity are
the dimensions put five people in here
and it will feel crammed you can't even
stand up straight now that's all right
for a couple of hours but for a few days
that would be extremely unpleasant
for the moment this is an industry
shocked by what it's seeing and hearing
but it also wants to know what went
wrong and why
Adam Parson Sky News in the Netherlands